one thing that is different this time
around though a lot of quarterbacks
issuing statements and white
quarterbacks issuing those statements
from Kirk Cousins to Jared Goff Ryan
Tannehill Andy Dalton Derek Carr Carson
Wentz and even Joe burrow who has never
taken a snap in the NFL he was one of
the first quarterbacks the time the
first one I saw right and simply as
possible the black community needs our
help
they have been unheard for far too long
open your ears listen and speak this
isn't politics this is human rights and
here's why it's important that white
quarterbacks are speaking up this is a
quote that Richard Sherman the 49ers
cornerback gave to Albert Brewer of
si.com on the issue I'm impressed with
the white quarterback speaking up
because those are voices that carry
different weight then the black voice is
for some people a which means the people
who refuse to listen to a black athletes
perspective will hear the same thing
said from a white athlete but receive
the message much differently so it's
awesome that more people are speaking
out because in sports you really have a
love and appreciation for your fellow
man regardless of race so these
quarterbacks who are who are coming out
and saying this is wrong and enough it
helps unite everyone in saying this is
wrong and enough now look there are
plenty of other things that are creating
division and argument in the country
right now around this issue but having
the white voices in the locker rooms
stand up and say this is wrong and
enough that helps become the catalyst
for change hopefully if it if if this
moment isn't the catalyst for change I
don't know what is but having that many
quarterbacks who are leaders of the team
and who are white joining in that chorus
Chris helps I think everyone come to
this conclusion when the dust settles on
this it's time for change it's time to
come up with a way to end these systemic
issues and to secure better treatment
for minorities at the hands of our law
enforcement yeah well because this isn't
about politics or anything like this
this is about you know human rights this
is about right or wrong and
quarterback's you know first off yes
being the leaders of the football team
the faces of the franchise you know got
the million dollar
smile got the money you know hey the
quarterbacks famous because hey he can
conversate with corporate America and
you know he can hang in the locker room
and and talk shop with the guys and do
all those things right so he is that guy
to be that crossover guy that Richard
Sherman's talking about you know and
first off by Joe burrow he's the guy
that I saw it I believe that was the
first tweet I saw addressing the George
Floyd incident from an NFL quarterback
and I just can't say enough about that
first off I just can't you know it shows
where this guy is his leadership how
aware he is a society people in general
it shows an even before this that you
know I thought he was that type of guy
so I really want to give him credit one
for kind of leading the charge because I
felt like Joe burrow let this out there
and then all the other quarterbacks kind
of stepped in line were like hey he's
right there's no doubt let's follow Joe
burrows lead so that shows what kind of
guy he is off the bat but you know this
is very important not only for our
community but hey as a white quarterback
in the locker room to you know again you
know a lot of these guys on the football
team of course are black there's a lot
of your best friends you know guys that
you've been around you hear stories that
they've had a deal with growing up in
tough situations you know in urban areas
or you know low-income areas and you you
do have a sensitive part in your heart
to all these issues and things like that
so to be a white quarterback you know or
be a quarterback in general you're
looked at as a leader but you can lead
in so many different ways and it's just
good to see the you know so many of them
come out there and kind of voice their
displeasure on the situation and and
just because others haven't it doesn't
mean they haven't fellow other ways to
handle the issue among their teammates
it could be that a quarterback who
didn't issue a statement has personally
spoken by phone to every single teammate
white or black on on his roster to make
sure guys are okay how are you dealing
with this are you okay do you need to
talk through anything
you know because look this all
fundamentally comes down to the
disconnect between the those
broad statements that supposedly govern
American life the things in the
Declaration of Independence the right to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness the the national anthem that
the text of the national anthem the
lyrics the land of the free and the home
of the brave are are we really free are
we all really free and and you know we
see in practice sometimes a different
reality than what we what we think the
country is about and these statements
from guys like Joe borrow and the other
quarterbacks we mentioned they are
valuable to me because they keep
everyone's focus on the real issue that
we need to solve because here's what
happens Chris what happens is the people
who are made uncomfortable by the
expectation that we are going to tear
the house down and rebuild it then we're
going to come up with a system that
doesn't include systemic discrimination
on the basis of race those people who
don't want to do it those people who are
made uncomfortable by it are deflecting
by saying it's horrible that they're
looting it's horrible that they're
writing it's horrible to doing this
because they'd rather do that then say
you know what these guys are right this
system swell we need to fight it so so
having these voices that are lining up
in unison that's not the way to pull the
issue back yeah you can be upset about
the looting you can be upset about the
rioting it shouldn't be happening that's
fine right don't change the subject
the underlying problem needs to be fixed
and having all these voices say that and
we're trying to join in that course as
well let's not lose sight of what we
ultimately need to fix walk so there's
going to be looting and rioting once a
year or twice a year or every time that
there's an innocent person or at least a
person who hasn't received due process
who meets a police officer decides to be
judge jury and executioner in nine
minutes or less yeah that's right I mean
that's what we're calling for as human
beings that's what these quarterbacks
are calling for a change in society you
know some of the people who are mad
about the looting and rioting show the
same passion and and be mad about a
guy's name being on someone's throat for
nine minutes or you know unarmed
african-american men being shot and
killed when you know there was no reason
to pull a gun on the guy and and in
general to begin with so you know that
is the big that's the point
and that
the point when you talk about is
specifically the white quarterback the
white quarterback can bring the
conversation back to where it needs to
be the white quarterback can get that
that white man on the fence right who's
oh you know maybe has some of those
racist issues fighting inside of his
brain to where you know a guy like Joe
burrow or Derek Carr or Ryan Kenna
whoever it may be he comes out and shows
the support for the african-american
community maybe that guy who is dealing
with those racist thoughts in his brain
and now we hear something like that from
a white guy and yeah it rings true his
screwed up as that maybe he might go you
know what he's right whatever that is so
you know there is importance here and of
course when the pedestal you have is a
National National Football League
quarterback you have about as big of a
pedestal as you're ever to get in your
life as far as that's concerned and
again this isn't about like oh don't
worry about ruffling people's feathers
or you know political correctness this
has nothing to do with any of that
that's where I'm sick of hearing people
say that over the weekend it doesn't
this is about right or wrong this is
about human rights it's about helping
people and I that's where I really
praise a guy like Joe burrow who I'm
sure took some flack for some people but
he doesn't care he doesn't want to hear
it because he knows what he's doing is
right by all people and no matter what
the color is we don't want to see
anybody treated like this by police or
anybody else but here's the thing
when you put it in these terms the black
community needs our help they have been
unheard for far too long open your ears
listen and speak this isn't politics
yeah human rights how could anyone give
that flag how could anyone deny that
that's the thing these are the anchors
these sentiments are the things that
will pull the people away from the what
about arguments from the deflection from
anything but dealing with the issue and
that's what we all need to do any of us
who have a platform need to constantly
remind people of what the issue is there
is a proven problem when it relates to
the intersection between law enforcement
and the minority communities and it
needs to be fixed and that's what these
players that's what people like Marc
Davis that's what men like
Brian Flores are trying to get folks to
stay focused on let's solve this because
the consequences of it are only gonna
get worse not better
we see it getting worse and worse and
worse they write the situation better to
end these issues all right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports